thank you very much for joining us today
thank you will wanted to open by asking
you how your approach to leadership has
evolved as you've risen through the
ranks in fence over 20 years
first of all thank you for it's very
nice having you here my big surprise is
this success about the trip I didn't
know that then
ten days of free beer would do so much
it helps well you know I had it there
very good luck of having great mentor in
Venza and before that I started working
I been working all my life since sixth
when I was fifteen year old every summer
I have to work I wanted to work and I I
had to work in a bank and I had to even
distribute milk or do a lot of a lot of
crazy stuff when I was in high school
when I graduated I I worked for for
three basically three companies I worked
for one company that is now owned by
Pepsi thank God not by by then that
message it's a cookie factory cookie big
cookie factory in Mexico and then I was
hired to go to work with my
father-in-law out of friends in a small
machine tool company called trace and
chrome and won the big the first lesson
that I learned there is he told me you
know I'm a shareholder of that company
your father is shareholders of the
company my father owned 25 percent of
that company and you're not going to be
the boss so you you better learn and I
don't want anybody to feel that you are
the boss so I said well it's not I
didn't understand why did you say he
said that and I started working there
programming production only the
production's scheduling then trying to
sell and he called me once and on
one very important thing that I didn't
pay too much attention by then and many
years later I learned that it's one of
the most important things that I have to
take care of he told me you know this
business has an only one big problem
which is it doesn't control its
commercial its own commercial agenda and
I said why is that we sell everything
that we produce yes but you sell it
through three only three distributors
that make more money than you so those
were the machine tool distributors of
Mexico two of them Germans companies
that control everything from the company
and he said if you want to be successful
in this business you have to go away
from distribution sell direct because
you have to control your commercial
agenda and we tried we hired I had to
hire the new first direct salesman and
eventually when we sold the company we
had 50/50 on sales digit and we were
able to control prices and margins and
the agenda this which was a very
interesting learning didn't come back
till now that I'm partnering we are
partnered with coca-cola coca-cola would
like to controller or agenda commercial
agenda we can never accept that price
like the prices of coke the public had
to be controlled by you by ourselves and
that goes also in beer and that was also
with also commercial agenda has to be
controlled and there's where you make
money if you go to let's say Walmart and
allow them to to start doing the cross
docking they call it and distributing
you do you don't have to distribute your
beer in all the stores you just living
in one one of site and will sell them
all over the country when you accept
that your death because they will
control your prices they will control
your inventories and
commercial agenda of consumer product
company has to be controlled by itself
that's one of the things that helped me
a lot then when I went to to fence up
one very important thing that helped me
a lot was to learn how to to respect
your team's decisions one of the
toughest things that I have to to
respect and to control myself is not to
impose decisions if you want somebody
that reports to your depends to you from
you to be responsible of what the he
does you have to okay advise him ask him
suggest him shield him but let him
decide obviously he knows that if he
fails I cannot blame bottom him and he
will be responsible of failing but if
you impose any decision you you are
first of all protecting protecting him
and second you are responsible of what
could happen so those those two things I
think have helped me a lot as I
advancing the scale of the business is
increased significantly especially over
the last few years went from being
largely in Mexico based company and now
having operations in nine countries yes
all over Latin America so what are the
some of the leadership challenges
associated with managing this
increasingly global organization and has
the culture of the organization evolved
at all do you began to acquire I think
that the culture from Monterrey has
helped us a lot and we have honestly
exported some of the good things that we
learned and we inherited from the
brewery has 120 years of existence never
had a strike very good relations with
unions and and we keep trying to do that
model in Nicaragua or in Argentina need
has helped a lot when we went to
Argentina first time what
that was the first outside country that
we went to we thought my goodness the
unions here are tough I mean this is
going to be a mess
we had to go there because coca-cola
told us look if you want to expand with
coca-cola you have to prove that you
read you're ready tooth time so we said
okay coca-cola Argentine is a very nice
country to live and to go to work and to
manage but it's very tough and honestly
it hasn't been the best the most
successful business in Argentina but
what has helped us a lot is that since
we were successful there we were able to
to convince coca-cola to get more
turtles from them and then that's how we
got to Brazil which is great country to
be and then we got Colombia and all the
rest of the of the countries now scale
helps a lot when you now we can dedicate
international relation people from
Mexico to manage to help manage good
relations with all governments unions in
these nine countries and we have a lot
of new ways of sending good messages to
to these countries when we went to
Brazil Brazil tax contingencies for the
company were very tough we were very
transparent with govern went there and
said look we want to clean this mess we
want we don't want to be tax evaders in
this country tell me what do I have to
do they charge us a flat fee to pay all
the to clean all the former problems
with taxes that we had and since then we
have been considered a good citizen and
the government of Brazil lights us and
helps us much more than than before in
Nicaragua for instance there's it's a
there's a lot of need of of social
programs there is a lot of poverty there
and we have experiences from southern
Mexico that we take to to Nicaragua we
are doing some water
in Colombia where there is a big water
program problem in in the rural areas of
Colombia and the experiences of Mexico
can be exported all over to Latin
America do you think those what you've
learned in Mexico could be translated to
doing business in the US or if you chose
to expand into other parts of the world
that's not a lot in America some of them
I think they they can some of them are
not so easy Latin America is very
different in the in the market the way
the markets run our products consumer
products like beer and coke we have to
distribute very small drop sizes to many
hundreds of flat or thousands of
retailers every day Mexico City on
itself has more retailers in number than
all United States that's incredible but
drop sizes in United in Mexico City are
two cases per store a week and in the
United States is 200 or 400 cases per
store per week so we had to learn I mean
the the brewery has very different needs
than brewing in United States and
Mexican brewery needs to be an expert in
distribution not only in marketing or in
brewing beer but in just in distribution
and you have to learn how to treat what
we call very small customers that buy
from you one case per week or two cases
per week in in the United States
Walmart or the supermarket's buy maybe
50 or 60% of all the Coca Cola's that
you sell in the United States in Mexico
maybe they account for 8% of the market
or or or less so the mom and pops of
Mexico are the are the our most
important customer by far and that those
are things that cannot be applied here
we always say well we've got
we have a big advantage on distribution
in Mexico because we learn about this
big problem how to cope with it but in
United States will be the power of the
Supermax it's sort so being that it
would be different
we've seen a huge amount of
consolidation in the beer industry most
recently with the anheuser-busch InBev
merger how has that consolidation
impacted Femmes uh to today and then how
would you anticipate it would impact
your business going forward well today
we haven't have we haven't seen the
consequences of that conciliation yet
the the big merge of of these two giants
in beer is starting thank God it was
decided when the prices of companies
were so high so now they have a big big
debt to fulfill and and that will give
us some time to to see them act on
behalf of their debt maybe five years
from now seven years from now ten years
from now that will mean not be the case
and they will be the strongest
competitor by far in the world we we are
completely convinced that there's still
a lot of room for local breweries or for
continental breweries brands are local
we have to continue doing well and much
better than anybody what we can do you
compete in every town with your brand
and that's how you have to be able to to
compete against the Giants now if they
come and spend billions in marketing
eventually they will they will hurt you
so I see that
the consolidation is not stopping and it
will not stop I think that there will
there are many ways of doing alliances
with others and there are many ways of
contra balancing powers our presence in
Brazil is very important I think we have
idle capacity in Brazil for maybe 50%
which can be used at a low price or
marginally if needed strategically wise
I don't we don't care to do that we
wouldn't like to have to do that but
that could be helpful that's a helpful
weapon if needed in the United States we
have to continue pushing our brands
getting a lot of leverage here
I mean Dos Equis has been great very
successful here and we have been able to
increase prices of Dos Equis in you know
in Mexico maybe three times inflation in
the last five years and volumes still
growing so did the foreign preference of
one of our peers or of one of our brands
gives the brand a lot of equity and
we've been able to make money with Dos
Equis in Mexico now the cattle light is
coming to Mexico so to United States
very well from a very small base and the
cut is always very very good now we see
that there will be more consolidation
that's what we see in the future for
sure attempts although public is family
controlled and I'm curious to hear your
view on what's different about being the
CEO of a family controlled business
versus the CEO of a business controlled
by institutional shareholders this is
very interesting and very important to
mention this company was founded by five
families in 1990 and since then one of
the
these were responsible for running the
company and the others were only
shareholders some since 1890 there are
board meetings where they had to inform
this guy responsible for for the burry
had to respond to respond and inform the
other four families or the other of the
families through the board and their
shareholders meeting since 18 registers
in 1890 so the company has been really
very institutional since the very
beginning that has helped a lot there is
a professional preference to have
minutes of every meeting informed
transparency from corporate law since
the very beginning and that has been
evolving quite well when we became
public I we I was not running the
company yet but they started to have to
need for new policies to be able not to
have the families deciding things
without contacting the rest of the board
members or the rest of the shareholders
now today I can tell you when I can
prove to anybody that there is no family
influence in a special way to the board
I the only difference maybe you could
say I have one meeting with which is not
one family with exactly five with the
five families where I informed what is
happening but I have never been
requested to do anything special or not
to present anything to the board they
are represented in the board we have
half of the board members are
independent and everything has been
decided and will be decided on the board
I've never I have never been
in the position of of having to do
something in favor or against any
shareholder if I'm requested to do that
I would leave the company because that I
don't think that's fair
for a public company so one of my
managers that passed away very old guy
always used to tell me you have always
to remember the dentist of Omaha and
that's a guy that maybe has a thousand
shares of friends are born in New York
Stock Exchange he doesn't know anything
about the company but it was it was
recommended by his fund manager wherever
and and he is suspecting from us to make
the most better decision for him as if
he was the only owner of the company and
that will that as long as I I will be
there will happen because I will never
allow anything to go beyond what is good
for the whole shareholder for the
hundred percent shareholder Mexico is
placing very well publicized challenges
recently ranging from this very violent
drug war that's going on in your country
to a recent outbreak of swine flu how
are these obviously unfortunate
developments impacted your business
specifically and perhaps more
importantly what is the role that the
business community is playing and
helping to get through some of these
challenges well first I'm coming back to
that the question before the prior
question that you made and I'm talking
about what is happening with these
crises that we're many crises that we
all these plaques that we have today
this wine flu and the drug problems and
the work global economic crisis that we
are facing also one of the advantages of
this we can call it family ownership or
or private ownership of certain
of the equity of the company is that the
long-term view is there and that is very
important
none of these controlling families are
there because they want to sell the
shares someday they want to create but a
long term value and that I think is very
important we we are not thinking or
worried about the next quarter numbers
never even if you ask me how are they
going to be I don't know and I don't
care because we see the long-term
potential of the company and that's how
we work for for that we all are always
making decisions that will influence the
numbers in the future not in that very
next quarter if you have to save some
maintenance to make the numbers of the
quarter looked nice your kin in the
company yourself and the message that
you're sending to all the ranks of the
company is very very bad so we we even
don't care about the budget we care I
only ask how what were you doing last
year however we do in this year and we
have to look for the next five years of
growth of the company now seeing this
crisis well Mexico has been a converging
country with all the typical problems
that we have would that we have and they
have which is every period of time we
have some kind of either political or
economical crisis this is the first time
that the economical crisis was not
created by Mexicans
that's good or nice we are in very good
shape internally but the bad news is
that the old ero industry which Mexico
depends a lot from is that it's in a
very badly bad shape and will be it
looks like for at least two more years
hopefully no more than that so we had a
big devaluation it's recovering a little
bit we are in a very good exports
position but not that way there is
nobody to export to so we will have to
wait on that tourism is very important
for us and growing my problem is that I
don't see sometimes the government to
prioritize on tourism as much as they
should I think because if we are all
convinced that it this is keep for the
growth of the country we should protect
it and one of the examples that we were
talking recently is that for instance
with this flu that we had I think the
government did very prudent things the
things that should have been done we're
done
protect we didn't know how harmful could
this could happen to the world and how
bad this Panda Mia looked like so they
closed the country almost and and the
problem was exactly only in Mexico City
and some other closed state called San
Luis Potosi basically when they started
so Los Cabos didn't know anything about
the flu and hasn't had maybe any case
what they should have done is they
should have say okay
Mexico City we will isolate the the
problem areas but the tourist areas
should be open to to United States and
to Americans or to Europeans that come
to those areas now the problem is
everybody in Europe hears Mexico the
world Mexican said no no I cannot go
there so Los Cabos is maybe with the
lowest
capacity use in decades clan is
going to suffer the whole the rest of
the year because of this and and the
government didn't consider touring okay
we should protect this and just isolate
Mexico that was one of the cases that I
think has been hurting knows the other
is the drug problem there are a lot of
reforms that are need needed to be done
by federal government by Congress
changes of laws and everything in order
to be able to fight against drug dealers
in Mexico in a more efficient way Obama
President Obama is helping is the first
time you see a position of saying okay
this is a joint problem and we will help
you and it looks like they are really
acting the Merida plan is coming and and
honestly President Calderon is fighting
very very bravely and I have we have to
recognize that this is a problem nobody
wants to have you have to fight against
big families that control the largest
business with the largest margin that
you could imagine and they have a lot of
power and this is the first president
that you see that he is attacking
frontally using the army and and being
successful that we you cannot imagine
how many because we only read outside of
Mexico the bad side of these four
killings and and the problems but I can
tell you in revelry on since the army is
taking control I think that husband may
be eight to ten times more drugs can you
say the commissar as I mean physical
fiscal eight eight to ten times more
people to send to jail cars taken houses
security houses discovered everywhere in
and if you compare that to the whole
country is the same thing
I mean Army is being very very effective
attacking this huge problem it will
never end the problem I don't think will
end but at least they will go hopefully
to some other region of the world alone
we need peace for a while the many of
the countries in which you operate have
health care systems and welfare systems
which are provide less extensive
benefits for employees then what you
would see here in the US or in Europe
and I'd just be curious to know what is
Femmes to do if anything to fill that
gap for its employees for 120 some odd
thousand folks that work for you well
you know the one very special
characteristic of the company is what we
started it started with a social program
very strong since 1918 it had included
savings and school and health care it
was basically in monterrey and then in
Mexico City and certain other cities we
took that concept to all over Mexico and
India we are taking it to every country
where we are more on a virtual way we
don't have a hospital we have a hospital
in Monterrey we don't have hospital in
Argentina or Brazil but we have the
services the health services
subcontracted in Brazil we have the
savings programs which is very very
powerful
they depth oldest magazine in Mexico is
is owned by well it's a magazine that is
issued by the company since 1918 which
is called rock we all work and save on
and savings and it's an internal
magazine that we sent to him people to
tell our company
people how to save money how to spend
their money and how they can be more
much much more productive those things
taken to to some of these countries that
never had when we went to Argentina my I
was very lucky to find out that
Argentina is very special the you know
it you learn Spanish in Argentina as you
could imagine he had a lot of fun and
not watching the soccer game you know
one of the things that is very important
for leadership and for all of you guys
when you start business you have to
learn is to ask the experienced people
about what has happened that's why these
programs I like I mean I have made a lot
of mistakes in my life and I love to
share those with somebody else to help
coca-cola coca-cola had problems with
the distribution company in Argentina
imagine sending a guy that was very
efficient running a bottom company a
small bucking company in certain cities
in the United States that you send it to
to run the Buenos Aires bottling company
and you become the star of the city like
this you have the best wines you have
the best company companies or friends
and you go to concerts and you know when
we were doing the due diligence process
two months now we do it in two weeks but
those years with accountants were having
a lot of influence in the company and
they were doing due diligence of two or
three months I discovered one of our
chief due diligence responsible buying a
smoking hard to buy as mobile
was wanted to see to our concert well
you know the last Stradivarius violin is
going to play here in theater : in
Argentina this is an event what does
this have to do with us well just you
know you have to be a social guy here I
said my goodness and I asked the
coca-cola executive what was the problem
when you were running this world you
know the last guy that run this company
here had two divorces and drunk became
alcoholic and it was amazing I said my
goodness I'm not I cannot send a
frivolous guy there a military guy
somebody so we we come I convinced me
myself to send instead of at the best
operating I come I sent a very serious
on his family guy and human resource guy
and and it was impressive
he had an interview with all the workers
employees workers production workers
everybody and 50 or 60% of them didn't
even know who was the boss never met the
manager 80% never had a handshake with
the general manager of the company of
the bottling company and we we
celebrated the first in 60 years the
first Christmas dinner with all the
workers together and the main part of
the program we gave a recognition award
to a guy that has been working for a
company 30 years and he has never been
recognized as so at all so they they
have gave him a recognition giving some
money and a watch golden watch of old
watch or whatever he cried in front of
everybody
the company was completely turn around
we had 700 lawsuits when we started
there
and two years later we didn't have any
lawsuit at all and that's because you
start talking with people and treating
them like human beings I mean we asked
them what do you want we'll want a
better dining room because we don't have
a good place to watch soccer games after
we work so we have to buy a big TV
because it's important for them to watch
the soccer game so okay we did that and
they stay they don't go to drink outside
they stay at the company watch the
soccer game after the time shift the
shift and they go home very happy loving
the company so those kind of things are
important when you go to outside Mexico
and what I learned is you have to ask
the guys with the experience I mean the
guys that suffered that those problems
did you know we're the guys that told me
what to do - or what not to do when you
go there I'd like to open the question
shrimp to the audience here in a moment
but before I do that the recent
marketing campaign here in the United
States of Dos Equis has been incredibly
successful needless to say and it's
revolved around this gentleman the most
interesting man in the world I imagine
he's a fairly came tanker employee and I
wanted to ask you what is what's it like
being his boss
we've been very lucky with the campaign
honestly it it's funny some of our
people said it's not going to work we
did focus groups and I saw so many
people loving it
we started asking the students all over
and it's shocking and it's amazing
the other big thing is that it has been
discovered gradually by consumers it's
not we don't advertise it on the Super
Bowl or whatever which is too fast it
has to be discovered and and you have a
lot of kids on YouTube because they want
to know what is the new thing and it's a
funny thing that doesn't talk bad about
beer I don't think that the jokes of
beer should go to kind of icon beer
drinkers or dumb guys or funny guys like
that you have to give beer what it
deserves beer is one of the best
products in the world in any any many
many ways very old is the best
alcoholism fighter that you can find in
the country it's proved by in any many
many ways that the high five average
consumption of beer icon height per cup
consumption of beer in a country are the
countries with low lower alcoholism
because you drink more liquid with less
alcohol and it really helps like and
enjoy and you enjoy them if you drink
good beer you will be healthy all your
life as long as you don't drink too much
control that that's very important I
keep saying I want one everybody
drinking one of our beers every day not
more than one but every day please and
that
are you good advice I think we have a
couple of microphones and hopefully if
you have a question please raise your
hand and we'll call you so we can hear
them on the tapes all right everybody's
laughing because I'm from Argentina
already say is true and we respect and
we loved your country a lot and we kept
on a lot there I have a regarding to how
you face human resources you are first
like a Mexican company and then you
expand into a lot of Latin American
countries I was wondering how you change
how you manage your human research
especially your top talent for top
management thank you it this is
important to mention the best thing to
create leadership or create leaders is
to move the people around the most
important thing that the leader has to
learn is to be able to manage hostile
environments or unknown environments the
the minute you feel very safe with what
you do the minute you are starting not
to to make your effort that's the
natural human thing make your best
effort I mean so we do a lot of exchange
of executives that's very important my
first big big exchange I made was in
2000 I took the CEO from the coca-cola
company coca-cola fencer to run the
brewery and the guy from the beer
business to run coca-cola everybody told
me I was crazy and it was the most
successful decision I've been made in
human research so since then
we have been changing everybody the guy
that is running Mexico for coca-cola
pizza today
last year was run in Brazil and
Argentina before maybe ten months ten
years very successful in Argentina and
Brazil not Iran's Mexico the guy that
was running Venezuela is now run in
Colombia he needs a little bit of peace
the God that is in been in Colombia he
needed a little bit more actions
Argentina so we moved all the guys and
that has been tremendously good honestly
is is very powerful my own experience
was when when I got invited to go to
work for friends ax I started on
planning and I think I told this when in
the trip of some of you to Mexico I
started on planning and and the beer in
the beer division had a very small
business that nobody cared and nobody
took attention put attention to this
which was the convenience store chain
call doctor we had by them 500 stores
losing all the money that you could
imagine and the CEO of the brewery used
to say I don't even understand this
business this retailing business is not
for us we in Monterrey are not
commercial guys we like to produce and
transform things we don't know I don't
know why we have this thing and I was
too I didn't learn to shut my mouth at
the appropriate time and I said you know
this business has a lot of potential and
it's a pity that nobody takes care of it
so this guy an Indian guy Indian from
Argentina you could imagine the mix it's
very very intelligent guy he's edified
now Shankar Dada was my boss by then I
said oh so you think that also has some
potential
yes I think it has potential it's poorly
managed okay why don't you go and run it
I said well if you want me to I will do
it all or let me ask you another thing
do you think it has potential I can
convince the board and maybe we can give
it to you for free you take this
business you run it for free you have to
be only exclusive on our beer and you do
whatever you want to the business and I
was very careful and said no no no this
is not for me I will run it for you but
I will not take it I should have taken
it so I went there and started running
that thing one of my closest advisers
told me when he came to visit me a month
later I was scaring to death I mean I
was saying why did I accept this thing I
don't know anything I don't understand
the business it was a mess total mess
and this guy comes and tells me do you
know what did they send you there
because they want to burn you and take
you out of group this journey you will
never going to make it I'm sorry but
this is the last business you want to
running in fencer so I started looking
for new team of people and all the
things that I learned in aqsa have been
very very important for my career what I
did change in the t-they employees
asking for new things clothes half of
the of the chain
we went down to 300 stores almost in six
months and try to understand to define
ourselves to create a vision to create a
dream with we were dreaming to have 1000
stores now we have almost 7000 and and
to make businesses to make money with
the same not when when I go there and
see what they have been able to do when
you isolate the business from the
brewery that was showering
it too much and ask them to focus on and
Sophia get the highest of mystification
on retailing as possible now this is a
tremendous this today is the most
profitable business we have on return
basis by far one of the most profitable
business in Mexico and with a lot of
potential to go into into outside so
another thing to learn is we always
these disregard small businesses because
we are so small that nobody takes care
of but you can you should never forget
that that small business can always be a
huge business if you if you find a way
to make it a huge business and the
second thing is that yes is the same
difficulty to run a small business than
a large business so a lot of people say
well when don't take put so much
attention to this small thing it's
better to run a larger thing but it's
better to run a small thing and to make
it large that's the best way of creating
value by fire so thank you for being
here first as a Mexican woman I'm very
curious to hear what are your views on
what needs to be done to have more women
in leading positions in our country and
in particular your company has done a
great job developing their employees
what are you doing to develop women in
your company you know this is very good
to do to here we have been very worried
about about having more women working at
the company it's incredible it's very
difficult to find women that want to
stay longer than needed in their careers
that I never thought of that and I
couldn't believe that but it's it's what
has been happening we have we had for
years a very nice lady working for with
us that is now doing her
MBA in Harvard she asked for a
permission to go for Harvard for two
years she will return hopefully in next
August she was in investor relations
she's from Wisconsin I think and and she
told me she asked me that question wants
three four years ago one night asked her
why don't you help me with that let's do
that let's let's see what we had to do I
am open to change anything is that is
needed to have more woman here and after
research interviewing them American
companies European companies all of them
told them told her if you find the
solution
please come back we don't know how okay
obviously Mexico is even lower in women
than many other countries there is lots
of things to do but at the end for
instance also has lots of women more
than the rest of the of the group in
actual the best managers in certain
areas are women and we want to move them
and we have to move them and that's when
they start saying no no I can't some of
them because they were married and some
of them because they when they have
children the first child would say I
will continue but second and then as
they grow it it gets very difficult some
of them have to decide whether they
continue being professional or not and
the last case I was told in aqsa was a
very good manager that said I don't care
I will stay and after three months of
trying she came back and said look I
can't and it's sad on operating side you
know which implies a lot of traveling a
lot a lot of things now on the on the
corporate side when you can do systems
or developing systems or nor any other
clerical work we are we will and we are
opening all the possibilities of having
flexibility flexible time schedules
work from your home programs those are
going very well and I think we will kept
keep a lot of woman doing having a kid
and a child and feeding him and feeling
the baby whatever and working with us
but at the end is not easy it's I think
maybe part of it is that we men as
husbands consider very difficult to
accept that we can do the child
education staying at home and having the
your wife working if she's better than
you she should be doing that or if you
agree you know we we I remember carly
fiorina did that when she had to decide
she was promoted her husband stayed at
home and it was a very good formula it
should work for more people I'm sure
that they're much better ladies outside
that should be working they can teach
because the flexibility of time it's
very open so universities you see a lot
of them but going to work and implying
traveling it's when it gets difficult
but we should do more I agree we have
time for one more question
hi my name is Eric date and I was on the
Mexico City trip so thank you again for
your hospitality both the great meetings
and also the the free beer I'm wondering
as you look ahead you know it seems to
me there might be other areas other
product areas that would work for
expansion potentially food could fit
with awk so and then there also other
countries to which you could potentially
expand your existing businesses how do
you balance looking for opportunities
for expansion and balance that with
sticking to your core competencies and
having a sense of discipline as a
company you know if you see the history
of the company we come from a lot of
extremely extremist positions we were a
brewery that it was founded as a brewery
and
since there were problems in the country
or the continent and the world war and
everything lots of external influence
influenced things to push us to God for
packaging and to produce our own
packaging and then we decided to we were
needed money so we had a bank and we
started diversification because of
circumstances then and and and the group
was went to steal also because the crown
cups were manufactured by by ourselves
and it was a good business to be in in
Mexico in the 40s and then the group
grew so much that split in two and an
alpha became another group with steel
and petrochemicals and some other stuff
and we kept the packaging related with
beer and beer and then in the eighties
we started up a big move of
diversification that started maybe with
with influence from the United States
when you remember the book in search of
excellence which is was a classic by
then everybody read that book and the
Boston Consulting Group approach and all
those things everybody said we should
have lots of companies so we went from
beer to whatever you could imagine
eighties and nineties and you cannot
believe how many different business we
were we we had plastics out of plastics
we had our plaque for for cars for auto
industry we have flowers we had canned
food we had pizzas and we had pizza we
have cheese we have beer we said let's
got peanuts and we have dinner
and cheese guys i mentioned she's
already we had burger ball which was
some kind of mcdonald small mcdonald
chain we had what we call the cold meat
called meat business which was
cemeteries and they call it they call
meat I don't know why business we we
well building house houses by millions
of houses called eggnog are broken
business since it started we were
fishing
we had three joint ventures for fishing
with French people Spanish people and
Japanese people when one of my lawyer
the lawyers that is retired mouth he
says I never saw it at the boat and we
never saw I don't know if they didn't go
out of the port look for fish when we
were losing money three of those things
it was kind of a race and everybody was
diversifying in the world alpha was
growing as we were growing it was crazy
so after that 82 we had a big
devaluation in Mexico we came back to
reality thank God
we had to sell everything I mean going
back to basics by then the only business
that we had was beer and coca-cola the
bank was taken away by the government
saying us then so we were coca-cola we
had coca-cola we bought coca-cola the
company bought coca-cola in sixty
million dollars the coca-cola franchise
for Mexico City we were so broke that we
had to go back to to coke and say we
have to sell it back we cannot operate
this thing with all a lot of money why
don't you buy it back and they offered
we wanted we asked 22 million we were
ready to lose 40 million dollars on the
coca-cola company franchise and
coca-cola did up
of analysis and they said we can offer
you 19 million my colleagues from FEM
SAP were offended because we were
willing to lose 40 million and they were
even asking for more discount and said
forget it we will keep it them and we
kept it tonight's a billion dollar
company a 10 billion dollar company or
11 billion dollar company thank God they
didn't take it but since then you know
we can become some kind of a trauma of
saying we are in beverages only and you
will say well why are you in retailing
well 60 percent or 50 percent of what we
sell our beverages in the in Oxon and it
gives us a lot of feedback from the
consumer will learn a lot from from
consumer that if that information is
given for free to coke and to beer to
learn about that and that's how we kept
why we kept talks and it and me because
it's a very good business so going to
fool which sounds logical from the
distribution point of view and the
commercial agenda point of view as unit
should be or could be a logical step but
up to today my board hasn't allowed me
to move I can I have an ask them to move
towards their maybe depending on how we
move and how we evolved we have been
concentrating on coca-cola and grown
with coca-cola and very very successful
and I'm sure that we will eventually
have more territories hopefully in the
United States also for bottling
coca-cola the partnership has been very
very good they respect us because they
need us and we respect them because we
need them a lot we are the best partners
we can each other fine I think um beer
we have to continue growing and
protecting ourselves against this
consolidation that is going to be
realizing in the future and will be very
tough wonderful mr. Fernandes thank you
very much for your time today we found
it incredibly useful we have a couple of
for you which nica's bringing over and
thank you very much for joining us here
at the Graduate School business